well speaking of another movie thing
that I love that you're in U Mama Mia um
do you think you do Mama Mia 3 cuz I
just had share here and we were talking
about I don't know if we talked about on
camera off camera but we were talking
about it about Mama m 3 and I was like I
feel like you should do it yeah I wanted
you do it I love okay do you cuz did you
grow up singing first because you're
very comfortable in that area I always
loved singing and dancing that was my
first love and I just I wanted to do
musicals and then I ended up doing more
acting but I that I'd seen mam Mia so
many times as a kid and I and I was
obsessed so that that show that role was
like this crazy like dream come true mad
moment I couldn't believe it was real
full circle full CLE kind of moment and
um yeah great songs great dancing it was
really fun I would love to do the next
one I think it should be about how the D
dynamos daughter and the dynamos formed
which is my idea but mainly because then
I could be in it but it's also a good
idea
cuz mainly I want to be in it but I
think that's an actually really good
idea oh that's
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home